the country of sweden one of the richest
in the world the one with free health
care often used as an example of good
governance is now also a cautionary
tale for some because of the way it
reopened in this pandemic it took a
totally different approach
from other nations that quickly imposed
lockdowns
instead sweden allowed its people to
live largely as normal
now sweden's mortality rate is 30
percent higher
than the u.s when adjusted for
population elizabeth palmer went to
stockholm
to see what happened the stockholm
vibe is relaxed stores and restaurants
have stayed open
throughout the pandemic and so have
primary and middle schools
how nervous are you now
about catching coronavirus not nervous
health officials believe just a few
basic measures like
limiting gatherings of over 50 would
control the infection
along with swedish common sense so you
are social distancing
as far as i can it's not always that
easy but i try
you don't wear masks no we don't wear
masks we haven't
no we haven't and neither do most people
i'm wearing my mask but nobody else is
but there's no doubt that sweden's
locked down light
has cost lives and one of them belonged
to helen gluckman's 80 year old father
yan
he was squeezing my hand when i was
talking to him
but on one stay he was he didn't know
you were there
i think he hurt me when jan tested
positive for covet the care home didn't
send him to the hospital
but gave him morphine and in days he was
dead
have you lost faith in your government
yes of course i've lost faith in the
government
with summer here sweden's outbreak is
finally slowing from a peak of more than
a hundred deaths a day to the low
teens but in a couple of months people
will head back indoors where the virus
could easily explode again but so far
there's no
sign the authorities are changing course
and that
alarms epidemiologist nella brussellers
if there is one country in europe where
there will be a second peak
it will be most likely sweden
because they're still not doing that
much to really stop it
last month sweden's prime minister
announced an inquiry into the handling
of the covet outbreak as
polls began to show that public
confidence was dropping
for cbs this morning i'm elizabeth
palmer in stockholm